Responsive design isn't just about flexible fluid designs, it's
also about adapting to different scenarios and environments, and
our primary tool for doing that is Media Queries.
Media Queries have their roots in the media type for
style sheets, used to declare a style sheet that's
only applied to certain media types; like when printing.
And in the at media section, in CSS, where
you can declare a subsection of the style sheet to
only be used for print or other media. For
example it's helpful to display the URL of hyperlinks
when printing, since you can't click on the links
on paper. So that's what this rule does, but
CSS3 Media Queries add a media query terms. This
let's us make condition rules in our style sheets
based on environmental factors, like the width of the
window or the orientation of the device. This opens
up a huge opportunity for us to make
truly adaptive layouts. There are a number of
different properties available inside these Media query expressions.
Like the width and height of the current window,
the width and height of the device, the
device orientation, the device aspect ratio and window aspect
ratio. Weather the, the device is grid based,
how many bits per color the device uses or
weather it's an indexed color device, or weather it's monochrome, the
overall resolution of the device, and
weather it's progressive or interlaced scanned.